ben showed me a video it's still kind of
it still sits with me
and can we play the audio uh yeah
do you know what i'm talking about yeah
i'll put the audio in right here are we
allowed to put the audio in
um i wonder if it could get flagged
especially this early in the episode too
it's really
heinous i mean not a lot of stuff
rattles me and this rattled me it's a
murder double murder suicide
in philadelphia over
the shoveling of snow i don't even
i guess there was a couple and they were
using a snowblower or they were using
shovels shovels yeah and they were
shoveling snow
onto another dude's driveway on onto his
lawn
onto his lawn yeah and
he there they were at at war
yeah this has been removed from twitter
now if you're trying to find it by the
way
and it's a video of the guy and they're
calling them it's a couple and they're
like
what are you gonna do [ __ ] and it's
like a scene from fargo
i don't know because it's snowing and
it's just blanketed
with snow and then the guy comes out of
his
house the guy that the the couple is
shoveling the stone on his lawn
they're calling him [ __ ] what are you
going to do [ __ ] we're going to make
your life a living hell we're going to
make your life a living hell
yeah i mean what a you know
when you say something like that
it gets to people when you choose those
words we're gonna make your life a
living hell
and he leaves his house shoots them
both in the street they're crawling
around in the street
then he goes back into his house what
does he get an ak-47 ar-15
ar-15 he comes back out
and he he looks at the woman and this is
where i
even as i talk about it it's creepy
you're watching the end of somebody's
life
he looks at her and he goes you should
have kept your mouth shut and then he
shoots her in the head
and then he goes and shoots the husband
it was so viscerally disturbing and i'm
usually not
disturbed i usually don't watch
executions all the time but i've seen
things
and i'm still this
video for whatever reason lodged
in my head and
it's because
i'm horrified watching it you get a bad
feeling from the moment the video begins
playing
you know something very bad is gonna
happen
it's eerie usually you don't feel that
but from the minute it starts playing
you go this
isn't something fun this doesn't end
in a fun this isn't a snowball fight
there's something about i don't know
what it is but there's an
energy there you go you know this is
going to go off the rails
you don't know how bad it's going to be
and then when he comes out and he shoots
them both and goes back in
gets an ar then comes back
out and shoots her and he hears the
thing
and then he kills himself right goes
back inside the cops come he blows his
head off yeah
and here's the thing right
you watch this guy shoot a woman
point blank in the face in the middle of
a street
with an ar-15
and right before he shoots her he says
he goes you should have kept your mouth
shut and you're watching
it and it's so horrifying
but
now now i have to be delicate here
but three little letters
what a word but
she should have kept her mouth shut
and the last things she's gonna hear
on this earth is the greatest lesson
she'll ever learn and it's sad
that it had to be that way
i'm not condoning his actions but
there's
something about shooting someone point
blank in the face
and delivering a message that they need
to hear
it's tough to watch
you could probably find it on the dark
web or something it's floating around
you don't even have to go to the dark
web it's tough to watch i don't even
even know where ben
finds these things i don't know what he
even does i don't know what he does with
his time
when he's not with me i don't know what
he does he just sits in his garage
and watching people murder each other
what what is wrong with him
but i was i felt bad that it ended the
way it did where everybody died
but i did i did feel
that that woman needed to hear and her
husband
it's not about gender that that woman
needed to hear
those words and it's sad that after that
he shot a point blank in the face
with the ar
but it's it's hard because you watch it
and you just you you watch the video and
you go
you know well number one
how's the quarantine working out for
everyone
uh because i this probably this might
have happened before the pandemic
or before this you know whatever it is a
pandemic but i mean before this
shutdown i don't know this last year
has has sent people
to the edge to the brink and when you
watch this you go yeah this
seems to be something that
is the result of people being pushed to
their
breaking point and he broke and he shot
this woman and her husband
watching them crawl around on the snow
is so rattling
it's disturbing watching them crawl
around
for a good 60 seconds i think crawl
around on the stove
watching that is really really disturbed
but but
but but
they were being very antagonistic
they were this is the thing
it's you it
they're saying that the guy gonna make
your life living hell
call him [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do and he just had
it
i'm not saying i enjoyed watching it it
disturbed me
i've covered that but what i'm saying
is that it's very difficult
to not understand
a fraction of the man's anger
he did not handle it in a productive way
you know i was taken back by though like
i've watched videos that are similar to
that before never that i
found like this freak but people
show me [ __ ] and go look at this i go
ugh
you know and and this really took a
mental residence in my mind
because it was just this snowy bleak day
in philly
and people it was just hatred on display
like a scene out of fargo like the end
of fargo
it was rough to watch
it made me deeply
sad truly about the future of humanity
and about
the effects that this period has had on
everybody
but i
did like seeing that woman get shot in
the face because
because sometimes you do want to shoot
somebody in the face point blank
and when he looks at it he goes you
should have kept your mouth
shut and she knows what's coming
and she knows she pushed the wrong
person and she's laying in the snow
about to get shot in the head this this
episode will get lighter
but as she's about to get shot in the
head she's laying in the street
probably what went through her mind is i
should have kept my mouth shut
maybe i should have kept my mouth shut
and it's hey
say it all around not advocating it
wouldn't do it wouldn't advise it
tough to watch not good don't go look
for the video it will be disturbing
unless you're into that in which case
it's great
if you're into it don't get into it
don't be that guy
unless this is how you come and try not
to be that guy either
um what were your feelings on the video
because you're the one who [ __ ]
brought it into my life
i'm sorry i'm so scared oh no i mean i
i think i've i think i've been quite
clear here it was a it was a mixed bag
it's like this weird like norman
rockwell scene where it's just a couple
shoveling their snow and then all of a
sudden
like within 30 seconds they're both
laying in a pool of their own blood
it's just i mean it's horrific it's a
horrific thing all caught on the
the by the way the video is from a one
of those doorbells
like a ring a ring cam yeah and then you
know halfway through it too their
autistic
son runs out the couple to check on them
and then when he sees him coming back in
with the ar-15 he runs off and then
that's when he does the execution shots
so there's like a whole scene developing
there of them trying to help
the mom and him trying to help his mom
and dad and then the guy just comes back
out
and does the deed well
i'll tell you one thing that kid's not
gonna step out of line
you know you want to talk about a polite
kid
you want to talk about a polite kid
i watched my mother get shot in a grill
for running her fat mouth and i've
learned to just
let it happen let life happen and i feel
bad for him
and i feel bad for everyone involved
here but
is there any better way to ensure
that somebody's gonna be
you know a little passive
i mean by the way those parents were no
great shakes
for that kid i'm not saying they should
have been executed in front of them
but they were not that was not going to
be
a great life with them you know
maybe there's family maybe the grand the
grandparents took him in i read the
article
better situation better situation
do you think in that woman's high school
yearbook
she was voted most likely to get shot in
the face
outside of her house while shoveling
snow
because that should be a new category in
philly high school yearbooks it should
be
most likely to get shot point-blank
range by an ar-15
by an angry neighbor who you are
harassing
it would be so much easier to feel bad
for them if they weren't like plus your
point what are you gonna do
[ __ ] that was your whole thing they
were like what are you gonna
do you do something about it you know
they would just like do something about
it do something about it do something
about it and then finally the guy
stopped what's interesting is he shot
them both he comes out with what a
handgun yeah with a nine millimeter and
he shoots them and goes that's not
enough and you watch the guy crawl into
the garage
again very disturbing and then he goes
back in the house and you think the
video's ending because she's like call
the cops
and you think oh the video's ending and
and i got to be honest
as a video as a piece of media
as media it's disappointing
because it doesn't feel like there's
closure
i'm being very honest the guy crawls
into the garage and then the woman is
like call the cop and she's still being
annoying
she's shot and in the street and still
pushing everybody's buttons
and you're like you know this is
needs a resolution and then he comes out
with the ar
and a part of you goes oh no
but then a part of you perks up because
you go
just a second ago i said there was not
going to be a resolution here
now i think there might be oh and there
is
and and there's something about
the the final words there really is
and again if you know these people i
mean
you know sorry
there's something about the final words
uh you
should have kept me out she goes you
shoulda kept
your mouth shut
he says that to her and then he just
blows her head away
and
then he shoots the guy then he walks
into the garage and gets him
we don't hear if he said anything to him
i don't think he did
because it's like it's hard to follow up
where you go you should have kept your
mouth shut boom
and then you're gonna have a real good
line
and now if you don't have joel and ethan
cohen doing it like fargo
you're not gonna have a good line for
the husband
i mean he could have said something like
when he walked into the garage the
husband could have said something like
you know
um i don't even know i'm on the spot now
but if he like looked at him and he was
like
you know uh i don't know like time for
you to join your wife
or something you know
something i don't know i'm on the spot
here it's hard yeah like a rotten hell
really when it worked it doesn't no
not after not after the very succinct
there's no fat in that sense you should
have kept your mouth shut
there's not one extra syllable he was it
was succinct
it was clear the message was delivered
with precision
as as are well the shots were as well
but to then to the husband you got you
he probably walked in there and from
split second was like
do i have something good for him too
and then he was like i don't and i i
just got to shoot him so he shot him
it'd be great if he just had something
good
you know but you know those guys at
philly he'd get hockey
he'd be like say hello to my little
friend like something hacky where you
like oh this is disappointing
that's the thing about long island any
of my friends
who will certainly do this i know people
who will definitely shoot people
in the face probably over shoveling snow
but the last thing they say to them will
be such a hacky
dumb derivative line
from like ace ventura when nature calls
like they will say something that has
nothing
to do you know they'll just they'll do a
jim carrey line from the mask
you know they'll be like smoking
somebody stop somebody stop me like
it'll have not
it will be completely cartoonish and
embarrassing
uh and then they won't my friends won't
kill themselves because they don't have
that level of intelligence
so then the cops they'll have to play
out in court what they said
and they'll be like some guy that was
like going like some neighbor that was
like
yeah uh i think he yelled say hello to
my little friend
and they're like the line from scarface
yeah he yelled that
and then he shot her in the head
you know like yeah yeah he said nobody
puts baby in a corner
and then shot her in the mouth we were
confused
we didn't know how the original argument
started no
nobody i know from long island would
have like to just say you should have
kept your mouth shut
it's a real movie
quality line to deliver
and i'm judging i am judging this only
as
media as content i am not
saying murder is good i am saying
as content as content because i'm a
consumer of content
as we all are and when ben showed it to
me i said well this is content
it's content it's a double murder
suicide he goes
he said to me he goes it's a double he
be warned because it's a double murder
suicide in philadelphia
over uh snow shoveling but then i i
settle in
and then i go okay but i'm still
expecting it to be good
right i still want it to be good and it
was good because
it's you think it ends and it does and
he goes back in the house and then he
comes out and he has a great line
so as content and what is it three
minutes uh two minutes and 20 seconds
it's perfect perfect for twitter yeah
yeah yeah perfect for twitter yeah
two minutes and 20 seconds perfect for
twitter
whoa and of course for igtv
you put it on ig tv with a nice cover
photo of the guy standing over the woman
with the ar-15
it's content folks don't get sensitive
i'm looking at it as a piece of content
as you should and that guy then goes in
and how does he kill himself what did he
do
uh i think the ar-15 just in the mouth
yeah
wow because he didn't want to go through
the trial he didn't want to go through
the whole thing
yeah it's getting bad out there
it's been bad out there